people were looking at my tweet they had
all these opinions but not once did I
talk about party I talked about the
things that was going on in the game
right everyone that I know and probably
your moms and your fathers were watching
the game on Christmas night too I'm ding
down my thoughts am I worried about the
49ers when I wake up absolutely not I
have two children I'm not worried about
the 49ers at all and that's for Debo and
whoever else I'm talking about the game
that's my fair opinion from my page I
don't think perie played bad obviously
interceptions the one to call Hamilton I
know he wish he could have back but I
don't think he played a b game we talked
about py being down can he play from
behind can he have that mvp moment where
he shows us that it's not a scheme and
he is that guy I think KY Shanahan is
obviously one of the best offensive
coordinators coaches in the NFL right
they obviously didn't want to get into
the drop back game because what there
was a lot of pressure they like to play
from ahead cuz obviously their defense
is so good that's all I was saying
there's nothing wrong with the truth
like I said I think P still having a
great year I have nothing against pie